what up freaks it is time for the evil
to rise once again jedites good morning
how are you I'm I'm Good Gregory how are
you sir good good good good good good
I'm excited to see what's in store Bruce
Campbell's championing for this film
even though he's not in it but uh him
and Sam Ramey have produced it leave a
like that would really be appreciated so
please go do that I I rise to the like
button let's see what's going on
foreign
it was a perfect day
of all I could think about was how much
I wanted
to cut you all open
[Music]
wow happy family
[Laughter]
oh Dad when I was just a little girl
I asked my mother
what is this Danny I found it yes
here's what she said to me
not now
nothing a big old kiss from you won't
fix
oh hell yeah
[Music]
yikes tattoos
yes it is yes
[Music]
awesome oh yeah
yes you know how to lie to kids
I saw a man
[Music]
[Music]
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
okay
cool
foreign
trailer that was a great that was a
great trailer yeah really really well
done yeah it was like perfectly intense
and Punchy is like the perfect little
bite-sized nugget of the movie yeah I
really enjoyed that a lot I really enjoy
that a hell of a lot I love to have this
franchise is just constantly changing it
up and a franchise that doesn't seem
like it they found a lot of the same
economicon dead eyes I mean or whatever
like a bunch of evil hijinks and set
pieces and chainsaws like they got
returning familiarity and whatever they
still managed to to constantly like make
it feel refreshing from Evil Dead to
Army of Darkness to Ash versus evil dead
to the the fetty Alvarez film now this
which kind of feels like
um a bit of a hybrid I didn't really
associate the footy Alvarez one as as
being like all that funny like there's
humor in there but this seemed to have
like some of that dark black humor that
I really like out of volt dead I'm
gathering my thoughts as I'm talking in
real time right now this had a good
splice of what fetty Alvarez did and a
little bit of what the first Evil Dead
movie did because I found myself like
laughing quite a bit during this but in
a way that was very enjoyable and felt
intentional at the same time this has
not the camp of Ash versus evil dead but
the gut punch of the fetty Alvarez films
yeah yeah absolutely it has that gleeful
energy that knows that you're gonna be
in your seat squirming and is out to
make you do so in any way possible
exactly yeah and then they said this
takes place in the city but this also
looked like a very like self-contained
film it looked like it was on one
location yeah most of it a really small
setting I mean you've got the apartment
but it looks like a lot of it is in this
cabin out in the woods or on this lake
or whatever it is either way all female
cast
it seems as though that's cool or pretty
close too it looks emotional too that's
the other part that I wasn't expecting
because you're dealing with Mothers
Daughters sisters and that angle because
usually it's like friends or something
you know friends or lovers whatever you
know well I feel like that's become the
new way to do these things past the Remy
era is like the ash ones I feel like
yeah it is like kids in the woods or I
brings this date to The Cabin in the
Woods our Army of Darkness is completely
removed from all that whereas like the
fetty Alvarez one has the whole like
detox angle and then this is like
sisters strange I guess I have a feeling
there's gonna be a metaphor here for
whatever the sister is dealing with that
is now becoming this demonic presence in
their lives and I think that's kind of a
neat angle for Evil Dead to continue
with like each time you know you're
gonna get the gleeful madcap violence
but you're also gonna get something that
does try to not tell the same kids in
The Cabin in the Woods Story the
original one you know helped to staple
down as a genre you know Trope this is
the kind of cast of characters that you
would see more in a horror movie today
and you're more elevated or is there
something like that where it is focusing
on on family and perhaps uh resolving
some level of trauma so I think that's
really cool to get a film like what you
would sort of get today but like this is
the Sam Raimi inspired version that's
what I'm most curious about because I
was watching the director's previous
movie which is called the hole in the
ground and that is very much the sort of
traditional a24 like okay it's a really
slow burn it's pretty much kind of a
mother-son drama of sorts with creepy
building elements so I was like okay
what's this Evil Dead gonna be like is
evil that has to be in your face so
there's a guy here before everyone
else's comments there's a guy in here
throughout the whole trailer yeah it's
like is there an actual I guess I was
just only noticing the woman
non-binary character I'm not sure but
yeah yeah and so I'm excited to see what
Lee cronin's take on something like this
is because I'm happy that you know
clearly he's got those kinds of chops to
do that sort of more uh dramatic
elevated horror type of thing but with
something that is as gleefully mad cap
and terrific as an evil dead I'm excited
to see how uh he brings that to life
yeah it's got the strong effective sound
design watch this right trailer with
headphones because it felt very
immersive it's got a great grip on
atmosphere I love the the different
types of shots that you're getting
throughout they had some cool locked off
shots here to deal and some interesting
POV perspective I I was I was more
impressed with this trailer than I was
expecting to be even though I know like
we were getting a lot of former praise
for it I heard it had an amazing test
screenings at the same time I guess I
was just sort of respecting a generic
ass trailer because yeah it was more I
was pleasantly surprised by it yeah you
could just do an evil dead straight up
but I feel like yeah they're taking an
opportunity to add to the Mythos as well
as recreate it yeah I enjoyed that a lot
that was awesome guys what did you think
about this Evil deadrise trailer how was
pleasantly surprised leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe and uh
hey let's end this with a
Chris Wham off you're the best guy here
we often make a big deal out of that
you're a selfless human being you're a
role model in this life and that's why I
feel like you would be the ultimate
character to be tested by the
Necronomicon if you and your friends
were to open that up and you were to get
possessed would that good spirit shine
through my dude that's the real test of
your character so why don't you go out
in the woods you know find yourself a
creepy old cabin do some Satanic rituals
and see if you can't prove your piety
beyond that sort of Temptation my guy
New Year New You and the new you is evil
so uh hey buddy hope you're doing well
hope your 2023 is off to a solid start
and we'll catch you in February March
April all the other months of the year
because you are loyal and we appreciate
that about you much love my dude talk
soon I want you to know that before we
shouted anyone out John's I was going
through the list of who's on our list
for the patron of the day shout out and
John says Chris on this list
he really wanted to shout you out for
some reason I was like this is gonna be
the one
[Music]